reject nation what is going on here greg
and aaron
aaron
alexander is back the first thing we
ever cover together umbrella academy
season two that's when we were good
friends now
not so much now there's been so much
tension you don't even see each other
how come you don't even talk no more
don't talk to me you look in the eyes i
was doing d12 anyway guys uh yeah i
figured if we're gonna do umbrella
academy gotta bring back air with me
he's the only one i ever talk with when
it comes to umbrella academy for for a
reason so yeah i'm excited to see what
season three is all about guys if you
can leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated helps us out on the
algorithm leave your thoughts down below
what you think about this episode or
season thus far and uh subscribe and
click that notification bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next
episode of umbrella academy is up
hopefully get this up daily or every
other day at best gonna do our absolute
best to power through and enjoy it along
the way full length watch long as we
sing with the time coder available for
our super sexy rejects as well as a
bunch of other shows where at the same
time you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
lastly thanks to the prepper boys for
helping us edit down these highlights
aaron you excited to start this
adventure i was born excited came out
the womb screaming we'll get sharp
eventually
let's do it
[Music]
oh i've seen sparrow origins
[Music]
yikes
jesus
this is the day this is the universal
day of the the 43 babies
oh god
on the 12th hour of the first day of
october 1989 reasonably smooth process
you leave one finger on my grandson i
slice you in half excellent i like a
spirited negotiator
[Music]
it's kind of crazy like you're redoing
the first episode of episode one
that's cg marcus
[Music]
oh wow spare academy's loved
[Music]
no
eyes oh trippy abc's through the raven
or the crow i mean oh like odin
norse odin not marvel odin
whoa
[Music]
oh next round's
okay still has a best friend someone
gave birth to a giant cube cool
still pepperoni
[Music]
they're number five yeah
and they stayed together through
adulthood yeah
it's the sparrow academy
oh
the flip perspective i like it i like it
dad who the hell are these [ __ ]
is that really you and who are the
weirdos on the balcony
[Laughter]
my children
looks like he treated them a lot better
right
[Music]
yeah wonder was that factor that
softened his heart a little bit
so i think it is this is our girl
this is lyla
i'm sorry what do you mean your children
that's not possible old man i think i'd
know wouldn't i see ben right cute hat
sundance they call themselves the
umbrella academy a group of scheming
perfidious male contents who accosted me
in the fall of 1963 when i was away on
business in dallas be warned they claim
to be my spawn
he remembers them wow
hi
i'm luther
okay
you slay me chris
it's hilarious chris i wasn't expecting
company she's alive
oh
what escape from or how
[Music]
dance off
[Music]
yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this has to be somebody's like fantasy
right this can't be real
maybe it's the venom thing on her cheek
i don't know
[Music]
it wouldn't be umbrella academy without
some dancing
[Music]
this is not a competition
this can't be real there's no way
oh
ben and claus are dancing
yeah five five doesn't dance that's how
i know
[Music]
yeah
you got 30 seconds
and if we don't
yeah yeah
yeah that's that dance spit you look so
much better alive than you do dead am i
right except that haircut what the hell
did you just say come on stop with all
the hostility mr grumpy
shut your mouth you shut your mouth just
hug your brother
ben
damn it ben
this makes more sense yep
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
you know even though you're a total
asshat now
i see you again
[Laughter]
i just love how chaotic of a start all
this is
you know for a blind person you're not
that bad he says
yeah just tell a rumor
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god so broken okay
this is great
there it is
there it is
[Music]
oh what the hell
oh
oh god
what a weird ass
wow that's fascinating
yeah you could
taste your own medicine would a rumor
work on him good question
i feel like it's only a physical thing
oh no way oh
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
oh god is she she turning real
she's hot
yeah she is he's a hot mannequin what
the heck
she's pulling some age of ultron wanda
[ __ ] right
[Laughter]
are they
[Music]
diego not dancing
see
bigger than always better so horror
graves like thought they were
he wanted to perfect it and so he got
new kids
uh that makes sense yeah
why are you even asking him he hates ty
what are you talking with since when
fine italian i could do it
god damn it luther why are you always
getting your ass kicked luther
my god
you again
[Music]
crazy
luther go get out
[Music]
fun yeah we're still gonna find out
what's in the basement i gotta go man
now these guys are too good
for you guys
i'm loving
it can't admit he's losing guys
those guys are too good for you guys
hey
i'm sorry
uh are you okay
yeah oh luther
hey
uh
i'm luther well don't believe me you met
her like two seconds ago bro you already
forgot about allison
hey
allison's always giving me mixed signals
fair
very fair
what do we do
you just stop pulling the door
you guys always losing track of your
goddamn briefcases
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey she didn't want to fight you
[ __ ] she didn't want to do it if we
forced her hand now we got another
apocalypse
it wouldn't be umbrella academy without
one
[Music]
[Applause]
how did he avoid it are you bro
don't you stomping luther on the ground
don't come back aren't you guys at all a
little curious
right
there's a little curious as to who they
are
[Music]
they need a lila you all right
i don't know yet
i've just never had my ass handed to me
like that before there you have it
here you go
it's your ass
dad didn't adopt us as kids he changed
the timeline so who knows what else is
different
i no longer have the briefcase five
where the hell is the briefcase
mom took it
[Music]
who's this [ __ ] harlan perhaps
no i don't think so
i did see him in the 60s
[Music]
lester
in your pocket
not ringing the bell tell us if we're
dumb in the comments
i think it's harlan
okay you know what i need to go find
claire i will catch up with you guys
later allison i care about my daughter
almost
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
like a haunted hotel i'll call clear
leader please tell her that mommy misses
her
and i'm sorry i forgot about you in the
60s would she still exist
that's a good question probably not we
attack the sparrows and we take back our
house and then we punch that a bit until
he admits that we're better and he loves
us more boom done we're wasting time
great plan diego i bet they're as wiped
as we are
really yeah i mean kicking our asses
looked exhausted
[Laughter]
big one is strong but slow
possibly stupid
some sort of
can someone explain how you got your
asses handed to you in 30 seconds do you
have any idea what would happen to our
reputation if anyone had seen that
jackass skin is really gross
[Laughter]
you summoned number one
sit
down hargraves to sit i wouldn't
underestimate the umbrella academy yes
their skills are as lacking as their
hygiene yet
somehow they saved the world in 1963 had
they not none of you would be standing
here now yes it could be a gray for
pricks
what took you so long to draw that
conclusion hard graves
[Laughter]
he just wanted to see how what happened
yeah she saw me for who i really am i'm
not ready to give that up i feel the
same about ray
go find old ray we better not have left
them just to die in some superhero turf
war you need to go home
hug your daughter
how do we know she
exists should go to the airport
and get back to your real life
what life
don't clean that blood off your face
though
just a quick just quick little dab you
know surely got some towelettes
somewhere
[Music]
definitely not a wig
[Laughter]
shot immediately after season two she
pulls the wig off
[Music]
watch what you do because we're watching
you the ad team got bars clearly
he packs six sandwiches
he knows something
dude get an ipod or iphone man get a
juke or something
maybe a
zoom
[Applause]
i think you're right
i'm good at this [ __ ]
doesn't harlem display some traits of
autism yeah
and then can't handle noises like that
and stuff so needs to calm down yeah
this [ __ ] looks so weird
[Music]
nice great eyesight you just it's your
eagle i gotta play waldo
together we're the only superhero game
in town we have this place under
complete control but if your people
start taking shots at us it will give
the sheep ideas we won't it's and i'm
just supposed to take your word why
can't you guys all be superheroes i came
here to tell you mine tomorrow morning
when your busloads of fans show up i'm
gonna be there on your front lawn
oh
and i'm gonna call you out for a fight
just you and me
why because your team is good
better than mine maybe
but i don't think you're better than me
marcus
you're just meeting spandex
and i bet you don't want the whole
[Music]
the suitcase briefcase
[Music]
she be watching it's like the crow
brandon lee god damn bird spies he's
making a deal with them
i'll handle it
damn bad
you're better dead what jacket is that
[Music]
it's like snake skin who is that what's
wrong
you look happy i am plenty happy
what does men need brothers who don't
eat like barn animals
dad didn't adopt us as babies but those
babies still existed here oh
just grew up in different places with
different people so where are they now
odds are oh
versions of ourselves
yeah buddy technically if you're near
your doppel for long you'll go insane so
if you ever see your other self kill
them sleep with them avoid
sleep with them
you pass them
well now they are because it's a plot
point doesn't it seem kind of rude the
dad unadopting us didn't change it oh
[ __ ]
i'm not here to stick around just doing
a quick little drop off i'm fine
oh son
what oh my god what
say hello stanley
hello stanley it's ashtray oh what from
freaking from florida euphoria oh my god
you're right
i've had stan for 12 years
it's time for you to do your part wow
have fun bonding
be good for mommy wow
do you got any food
a kid's an insane boxer
is he really yeah wow
don't touch it grace
don't do that don't be dumb
no marcus
it's a message from god
listen you're a robot
[Music]
we love to see people do dumb things
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
interesting
[Laughter]
that's what you get from being stupid he
sounds like god
[Music]
we save the world we stop the apocalypse
yes
kill all the things kill
[Music]
them top billing
all right
one episode down 45 more to go
means all right let's talk about it
all right man what'd you think of this
episode huh
what did i think of this episode i think
that um
obviously i like the characters i like
the the fun stuff that umbrella academy
does with its weird reverent humor
i'm not in love with it so far no no no
no no i think
i think
tv has this thing where they they create
problems and then they create
a logical ways of character confronting
those problems for the sake of a plot
and i think that this episode is very
guilty of that
like they just dealt with time travel
and then their immediate reaction to
seeing that they're in a alternate
timeline is oh we gotta [ __ ] fight
them ah you gotta punch all our problems
away and i was like that's okay all
right fine it was fun to watch but i was
just like that's not
how logic works
and then i don't know just
they they raised certain questions that
felt
i don't know it was just it didn't
didn't feel
natural to me but you know for the sake
of the plot i think we have to go there
and i think it really has to
we need more time to see how the show
execute the things that it's trying to
do but you know everyone's on their
a-game you know as far as the the
chemistry the chemistry between the cast
is just as strong as ever sure and i
thought it was interesting seeing that
this feels like a direct jumping off
point from the last point we saw so if
you haven't seen season two in a while
what like two or three years like good
luck because gives you no sort of
uh room to kind of like be like remember
this unless there's like some real yeah
yeah but we didn't watch that yeah i'm
still trying to get a a i mean it's the
first episode and and netflix designs
the show like umbrella academy to binge
so you don't want to like there's a
reason it's not week to week they want
you to judge it off of the first episode
um but yeah i mean because i think i
think it's an unfair comparison because
what i respect about it so far is that
it's it's already very
different than the other two seasons and
and season two felt extremely different
than season one
and this feels more like a
sounds like a weird thing to say it
feels more like a superhero show
and what i like an umbrella cabin is one
of those shows that feels like
anti-superhero show so i'm still trying
to get uh my mind and heart are still
trying to wrap its itself around like
what exactly is the pacing of this
season what exactly is the
the tone of this season because
i'm i'm still not quite grasping it it
felt like it was moving like really fast
and not in the complimentary way
umbrella academy generally moves like an
at a fast pace like i was really
appreciative when it actually started to
slow down a little like when it starts
slowing down that's when i was like
actually really into it yeah um because
yeah i was kind of it was kind of a
mixed bag for me because i think it's
just getting reacquainted and
reintroduced and um
yeah because nothing was really
emotionally grabbing me as much as like
being excited about certain things like
seeing lila show back up and enjoying
the fight scene at the top of the
sparrow academy you know but the
i don't know the sparrow academy it's
like they're uh
a lot of it's just sort of waiting to
see what they're all really like because
all i really got from them was just a
bunch of you know angsty
one mind hive one noted brats
very very elite kind of team unit that's
very uh kind of pompous about it the
thing that bothered me i think the most
in the episode was the fact that five is
supposed to be the smart one of the
group but they've done very little to
question the nature of
what else has changed outside
what else has changed with them being
there like from the moment you see that
there's another academy like a sparrow
academy i feel like you'd be like oh
yeah okay so if this is different then
all these things are different and the
fact that
allison doesn't even question the fact
that huh if this is different maybe i
don't even have a daughter i was just
like that seems just like
like a no-brainer like me yeah it's when
us as an audience is ahead of the
characters it kind of makes it a little
distracting because i think that
that's what smart writing
should be is either subverting
expectations or
doing things that were we're on the same
page like we're going through it as the
characters but if we're smarter than the
characters it makes a little frustrating
yeah i felt like the first episode of
season two especially it was a long time
since i've seen season two obviously
it's been so whatever first came out
yeah but i remember the feeling of being
like not only is it a good setup episode
it's just a really good episode and this
felt like okay this relax they're just
setting up a lot
and it's kind of fast-paced and quirky
which is a quality of umbrella academy
but i think the kind of like the the the
depth is is the thing i was sort of
craving a little bit more of
you know and uh i don't really know what
to be honest i don't really know what it
is i'm craving i really know what it is
that i'm expecting
um because yeah i think the sparrow
academy was kind of like other than the
powers on display which is a cool
introduction
this made this it seemed like this
introduction this reintroduction back in
umbrella academy the series like it was
mainly set out to be
um
fun but there's something about its tone
i wasn't as gravitated towards as i was
with the first two seasons and so it's
just maybe take some readjusting because
like yeah the spare academy just seems
like cheesy yeah
they they seem they seem like uh
especially ben uh yeah he's just super
angsty for like no reason like why are
you like this bro
yeah they all again we haven't really
spent much time with them the show was
designed to binge so i know like well if
odds are if you're watching this
reaction or this discussion you've
probably already finished the show or
are way ahead of us on the show
so you're probably topping away yeah
what i'm like yeah i get it all right so
our i've had that experience many times
with shows on this channel where i'm
like not a big fan to oh my god i'm
loving this you know and i it's umbrella
academy so it's not like it's lost my
faith in it but yeah as a as a premier
episode it it was just like it was kind
of like quirky and fast and we got to
set up here like they're at the hotel
obsidian
and um
yeah i guess it just lacked weight for
me i think the thing i would like to see
is
want our characters
making smarter decisions great i know
there's a lot of humor in it and but i'd
like to see
some
some real thought behind their actions
and things that make sense for them i'm
also a little confused about what
the show's intention for how we're
supposed to feel about the sparrow
academy is i'm like are we supposed to
like be like screw them do they want us
to eventually like them i don't know
but one of them's dead already so i'm
sure that's going to be like the mystery
oh on the sparrow academy's end while
the umbrella academy is trying to do
their own thing and then run across
their their doppelgangers and whatnot so
yeah and they're setting up this
i wonder that thing in in the basement
that oh my god what is what's the mom's
name again i can't remember
grace grace yeah yeah uh grace um
i wonder if that's connecting a little
bit more because they had the whole
reveal with hargraves in the last
season that he's an alien
and i wonder if it's kind of connecting
to that yeah you know that could be
interesting because it seemed like it
was much like alien computing technology
yeah you know and you know grace is
designed i don't know kind of this
traditional boomer sense
and it's a sign from god
so
i wonder what that's linking to
and
yeah you know it's like some stuff is we
gotta we gotta kind of wait for it to
unfold but right now it just felt a
little bit more
it's not messed up
felt a little bit more like i was
watching network tv
yeah i was trying to be umbrella academy
yeah i don't want to be too harsh though
i really don't know again this is only
the first the first episode like we
can't get ahead of ourselves because
we're going to watch them all back to
back right yeah no yeah first season
felt like they were an adaptation of a
comic book with creative liberty second
season it felt like
when they ended season one they're like
okay we want to take this in a different
direction but we have this inspired idea
that we want to take this to and explore
these characters in the 60s and then
this season we're like oh [ __ ] we got to
make a season three
alternate timeline sure let's yeah yeah
but so it didn't feel as um
as it felt
very
very plot oriented that's uh instead of
character oriented i feel like granted
it is a plot because like the the whole
seven day thing at least the first two
seasons were but i think that
the
at least the premiere of season two did
a very good job of
having it introduce the plot but also
catching us up with how these characters
were in their head spaces yeah so
granted it's only the first episode so
you know i'm just saying that to be nice
like
i think it's more of the feeling that it
leaves with is is that
um like what i like about it is what i
like that's carried over is is the
characters from umbrella academy i like
that and i like that i like the display
of powers from the sparrow academy
and the chemistry is just as strong as
ever i think what this felt like it was
lacking for me
for a setup is tension and yet this
should also feel like very consequential
and yet the characters responses to
everything just feels like
i get it they're defeated they're coming
off of a really big battle from before
and they're all like tired yet it feels
very inconsequential to them in a lot of
ways
you know and so i guess we got to just
see what's in store as it goes because
yeah 99 of people who've watched the
first episode we're like all right next
episode let's go yeah yeah yeah it feels
like people aren't stopping to like
think about and ponder what they thought
about that first episode right now yeah
it feels like character feels like
choices writers made for characters to
go rather than
choices that characters would make that
make sense for them i really think it's
just more of the response to things it's
like i like the setup of the sparrow
academy
and being here and they're being you
know stranded once again like there they
should be at a place where it feels like
we're back at home we did it but yet
they're lost
and
everything is just
kind of a light
attitude towards it all after they fight
the sparrow academy yeah you know like i
was really into it at first but then it
just started to kind of dip for me in
terms of interest
um
so
yeah but they're trying something new
they're trying something different and
they got it they can't just repeat you
know like we're stranded again
apocalypse
i'll give i'll give the show that yeah
each season has a very different thing
that they're trying to do and they're
keeping it they're keeping it fresh with
the inventiveness of the plot so i'll
give them that i see the execution for
me so far i'm not 100 vibing with but i
respect the ambition and the setup of
diego i think is fascinating like with
lila coming back and having the kid who
where it's like they all have their
issues with heart graves uh you know
wanting to be accepted
and but diego is probably the the
funniest when it comes to
this this like uh this constant
just determination to get approval
and so now how does he handle being a
dad himself you know yeah so i really
like i like the setups all around um
and it feels like there's gonna be a lot
happening at this hotel uh that's gonna
be very fascinating to see what unfolds
but hey first episode done hopefully
stick around
and see if we like the second episode
and so we'll just gotta be honest that's
the only thing we can do is be honest
all right guys subscribe click that bell
leave a like and uh let's on this with a
patreon
tyler hague
my dude
i hope you're doing well man i know we
only catch up periodically on twitter
once in a while
but uh we miss you dude we miss you and
with this being umbrella academy
superhero show
you're a good person to shout out for it
because you know in a lot of ways you're
like a superhero
superhero
in our eyes because you know you're like
uh
you demonstrate loyalty commitment a
good heart
just so kind you're like the perfect
perfect specimen
of a superhero in fact you're the kind
of superhero that we would probably want
to draw blood from dna study it see what
we can do to make you
duplicate duplicate you around and that
way we can create a soldier an army of
tyler hanks
to protect us
in this world
so tyler
thanks for being the perfect project my
friend
[Music]